now if you are looking for a surprise
weapon against the mu 1 e5
then you came to the right place
because in today's lecture i am going to
show you
one of the surprising gambit which has
been rarely played
but yet
very tricky over the board
[Music]
after e4 and e5
white should start with d4
and after pawn takes d4
here white has tried various responses
such as
c3 leads to the golden gambit
queen captures d4 leads to the center
game where knight to f3
enter into the keys risky gambit
however there is a fourth big time
alternative
and that is
this
wonderlassa gambit starting with
bishop to c4
so if you are a bishop's opening player
this might also interested you
now as you can see i have highlighted by
the arrows black has plenty of choices
we will start with the least popular
choice to the most frequent one
the first move i want to consider is
bishop to c5
which i can't tell you how many people
has fallen into my blitz games
as now white get by force winning
sequence
bishop takes f7
king takes f7
queen to h5 check
g6
and now white regained the piece back
with queen capture c5 whereupon
not only black king has been completely
open on the king side
but already there is ongoing pressure on
the d-pawn
which all together gives white a great
advantage
the second move i want to consider is
bishop to b4 jack
so all this bishop moves
has some huge problems because after c3
pawn takes c3 and b takes c3
can you believe the only move for the
black here is to play queen to f6
to hold on to his game
because if
the black square bishop moves anywhere
then once again the game has been lost
at the opening stage
for example if bishop to e5 then we have
this nice tactic
queen to d5 winning the piece
as white is threatening double
queen takes f7 mid and queen captures a5
which unfortunately black cannot defend
both of them
well the same story goes if he goes on
the e7 square because after queen to d5
not so surprising black cannot defend on
f7
as the only move knight to f6 completely
fails
due to bishop takes at 6 castle
and bishop to e3
white obtained a whole piece at just
eighth move of the game
isn't that amazing
okay
what about the last move bishop to c5
and i think you already see now yep what
we are up to is
bishop takes f7 king takes f7
queen check g6 and queen capture c5
again and again we have the scenario
where black king has been displaced
white is getting his material back
and practically speaking it is only
white who is having
all the fun in this line
last but not least what to do against
the moon queen to m6
and at first sight this looks obvious
choice except one problem that
white has a nasty exchange set here
starting with c captures b4
the point is we get some forcing moves
queen takes e1
queen to b3 attacking on f7
so queen to f6 is more or less forced
and now
i'm going to introduce a new move here
and that is
knight to e2
which is so far never has been played in
any game
and i just like to show you how
dangerous this move is
as i have won a very quick game against
a 2200 plus retail opponent
my opponent continue with some obvious
moves
knight to e7 planning to castle
i continue with
bishop to b2 attacking the queen
queen goes to the g6 square
whereupon i simply castle
after the natural move castle
i think black is clearly lost here
as white has very simple attack
knight to f4
queen to f6 has been played
but after queen to g3
black has some serious ongoing issue on
the g7 square
the matter of fact is in the game my
opponent made a decisive mistake
by playing knight to c6
as that allow this nice
knight to h4 move
which
create a triple attack on g7
and just like my opponent if you think
that
g6 solved all the problem
then you're absolutely wrong
as after just one move
queen to c3
and black is completely lost
the third move i want to consider is c5
which is in fact played frequently at
below 2000
and against this
even though white has plenty of choices
i am going to recommend this
straightforward move
c3
which sets up some connect tricks
first let me show you
probably the most high profile trick in
this line
where
if black capture this pawn believe it or
not but white is winning on just
fifth move of the game
yup you heard it right
look at next reply
queen to b3 attacking on f7
queen to e7 defending as well as
attacking on e4
but after knight to c3
no matter however black wriggles
he is going to lose this key
for example if we continue with knight
to c6
planning to go knight to e5
here we can unleash this nasty move
bishop to f4
whereupon if black indeed goes with
knight to e5
then
we can really surprise him with queen to
c2
the point is after knight takes c4
white has this decisive blow
knight to d5
where he has a double threat number one
not only attacking the queen but looking
at the juicy c7 square
and number two very obvious
queen capture c4
in fact there is a game in the feed a
database which finished very quickly
black played queen to d8
white indeed give this check and after
king to e7
yup simple move you take the knight
and threatening the rook
so that if black foolishly played the
move rook to b8 then after knight to d5
chat
king 28 and bishop captures b8
yet another short game
where white obtained a piece at just
13th moon of the game
so guys watch out for this nice high
profile trap
if your opponent continue with knight to
c6
the second choice knight to f6 is not
good either
as we can simply continue with bishop to
g5
pin down this knight and threatening
knight to d5
something that can be turned out
horrible for the black gang
for example i can show you a model game
between two 2500 rated opponent
where black continued with knight to c6
so his idea is that
he's threatening the move knight to a5
as well as
knight to d5 is not a threat right now
as black can always play the move queen
captures e4
okay in the game
white played the most accurate sequence
castle on the queen side
now threatening the move knight to d5
and indeed after knight to e5
white just given up the bishop pair by
playing queen to e4
but even after this the position remain
so much venomous for the black
well he tried queen to e6
but unfortunately this runs straight
away into the move knight to d5
and now black has two choices but
neither of them give any satisfaction
result
for example knight catches d5 is a big
time blunder
as after e captures d5
queen has to stop rook to e1
and the only way to do it is by playing
queen to e5
but this doesn't hold the ground as
after knight to f3
queen is forced to go away so that
we can deliver this nasty check
which in fact yet again
finished the game
just within the opening stage
so knight captures d5 is not a good
choice by the black camp
in the game black tried to move bishop
to d6
but this completely fails after the next
nice sequence by wide
bishop takes f6
pawn takes f6 and now queen to c3
whereupon he has a very simple threat of
capturing on f6 square
and mind you
bishop to e5 doesn't work here
as white has two good choices
he can take on c5 regaining his material
back
but the even stronger choice is you go
queen to d2
with the follow-up of queen to h6
and in all of this instance
it is white who is clearly on the
driving seat
instead of capturing on c3 the another
popular choice here for the black is
knight to c6
defending the d4 pawn
whereupon my recondition is you continue
with knight to f3
now if your opponent continue here with
knight to f6
then we can certainly capture on d4
and the position will transpose into the
max length and the morphe attack
territory
which i have covered in detail
in my teachers tricks
sixth and the seventh episode
so the second most popular choice here
is d capture c3
but after this we can simply take the
spawn
and it doesn't matter however black
plays
our planning is very simple
we want to play queen to b3
followed up with castle on the king side
which already gives wide a huge attack
let's follow the database for a while
for example the most popular choice here
is
d6
we continue with queen to b3
queen to e7 is a bad choice as somewhere
down the line white can unleash knight
to d5
as we have seen
in earlier games
so queen to d7 is the natural choice
but after this the simple plan
you play bishop to f4 and pressurize the
d6 spawn
okay
black can even play knight to e5
and get the bishop pair
but after queen to b5 i think still
white obtain a decent advantage
you cannot take the queen here because
after bishop takes
bishop to d7
bishop takes d7 king takes d7 and the
move castle on the queen side
not only white is going to get his
material back
but black king is stuck in the center
where white can get all sorts of fun
attack in the slime
so no queen captures b5 is a bad choice
by the black cam
the correct move here is
knight takes c4
but even after this white can simply
recapture this piece
and black sum of the natural moves
doesn't solve the problem in this
position
for example knight to f6
you pressurize this backward pawn with
rook to d1
and bishop to e7
straightforwardly matt with e5
where there is a nice trick exists
if your opponent continue with
knight to h5
just look at the follow up guys
white plays bishop to e3
so now there is an indeed pressure of d6
pawn
and engine's best choice queen to e6
completely fails as after knight to d5
and the move castle
white can play a move
which force the instant resignation
can you find it
congratulations if you see the move
g4
what a move
as it by force winning the
piece
because this knight cannot go anywhere
and mind you
queen cannot capture this g4 pawn
as white has knight captures e7
winning the piece
the third popular choice by the black
camp is
d6
but personally i don't like this move as
black is already limiting his dark
square bishop
and although
white has plenty of choices here
i am going to recommend this attacking
move c3
so if now black doesn't capture this
pawn then we get a very good center
so by far the popular choice is
capturing this spawn
whereupon
i think you already guessed white's next
move
yup
queen to b3 attacking on f7
queen to e7
now you take the spawn
threatening knight to d5
and after knight to f6
we can continue with knight to f3
if knight captures e4 then white can
simply castle
and expose the e file by his rook
so that's not a good choice and if you
look at the database here
by far the most popular move is
knight to c6
which i'm afraid leads to a disaster
after white castle
and would you believe
all of the top choices by black
miserably fail from here onwards
for example if bishop to e6 then we can
take on e6 and if black capture with
either of the b's
we can take on b7
and emerge with an extra piece
so that's not a good choice
here what about the second move g6
well this time around white also has
some natural attacking moves
bishop to g5 pinning down the knight
bishop to g7
and now knight to d5 complete
the attacking route
as
after the forcing sequence
queen to d8
e5
knight takes e5 knight takes e5
pawn takes e5
and look at this final
silent but the killer move
rook to divan
and even though black sees that
the night discovery is going to come
unfortunately he cannot do
anything about it
last but not least
what happens if instead of g6
your opponent continue with the move
knight to a5
typical tactic
getting the bishop pair
where this time around this doesn't work
here
because white has a nasty high profile
trap here
starting with queen to a4 jack
okay knight to c6 has been forced
and although
database suggests knight to d5 is
white's top choice
i am going to improve upon this
and suggest a move
which wins on the
spot can you spot it
congratulations if you find the move
knight to g5
which again creates some forcing moves
bishop to e6
knight takes e6
and after fx e6
the beauty about the modern chess engine
because i think
the next stunning move only engine can
find it
look at this guys
bishop to a6
boom
amazing
obviously black cannot play rook to b8
as after bishop captures b7
he is definitely going to lose a piece
as rook to b7 miserably fails due to
queen capture c6
and black is losing the rook
so that is right out of the equation
but many of you thinks that hang on
isn't black and castle on the queen side
and get rid of all the threats
well yep he can accept one problem that
after white's next reply
white instantly get the winning position
you are a genius if you see the move
queen capture c6
a beautiful move on his own right
and the big time pointers after black
regained his piece back
white get this tremendous attacking
position
starting with queen captures a6
king to b8 and bishop to e3
where the position looks so scary for
the black
and if you think that hold on
c5 can hold all the ground
then think twice
as after this can opener
b4
white's heavy artillery come into the
picture
and not so surprising
some games in the database finished
very quickly from here onwards
now before we leave i like to quickly
point out
what you should do against the two black
knight moves
first move
knight to c6
you have two options
number one you can go with the move c3
and enter into the goring gambit
territory
which i have covered in detail
in my attacking chess gambit third
episode
and the second big time alternative is
you can continue with
knight to f3
and enter into the scotch gambit
territory
whereupon
against the two black major choices
number one
bishop to c5
once again i'll give you two choices
you can castle and enter into the max
length territory
or else
you can play the move knight to g5
and enter into the saret gambit
which i have covered
in some sort of detail
in my chess trap 46th episode
so kindly check it out this dangerous
gambit if you really want to surprise
your opponent
okay
what about the second big alternative
knight to f6
and against this
once again i'm suggesting two good
attacking alternative here
if you really like the fried liver or
the lolli attack
then you can go ahead with the moon
knight to g5 here
and apart from it the second alternative
is you can castle on the king side
and depending on the black respawn
you can enter into the max lang and
the morphe attack territory
which i have shown in my dirty chest
tricks
and the 7th episode
finally
what to do against the moon knight to f6
and i'm sure if you have followed my
dirty chess tricks playlist
then you will not find it difficult to
find white's next reply
yup
knight to f3
and we have entered into the
uroso gambit territory
where black has plenty of choices
but each of these moves i have covered
in detail
in my dirty chest tricks 14th and 15th
episode
do watch out if you haven't so far
and you will be amazed
how quickly
white get aggressive and attacking
winning positions
that's it guys
i am sure after watching this video now
you are confident enough to include this
line in your rapprota
remember after this three rare bishop to
c4 move
not only you have chance of finish your
opponent very quickly
in the opening stage if he played some
careless moves
but even some of the strong and solid
moves
white attacking ideas cannot be
denied and certainly
this line should be used as a complete
surprise weapon in the tournament
practice
thank you for watching this video
feel free to like subscribe and comment
and i will meet you in my next episode
very soon
bye and take care